don't worry i'm not gonna do any jokes  about the supreme court ruling i had a  couple i just you know i didn't think  they were ready so i  i took it very seriously but i had to do  what was best for me you know  i don't know if you guys understand how  hard it is to raise a premise to a set  up to a punch line it takes a lot of  time and love and care and i just didn't  love it like that you know what i mean i  didn't know if i could give it the love  and needed the resources it needed you  know what i mean i just i'm a single  comic out here  and i have other premises to raise so it  wasn't  it wasn't an easy decision but  at the end of the day i had to terminate  the punchline and that's just what that  was  [Applause]